whereas in particle physics it tends to
be oh everyone's thinking about Dark
Matter that's the thing I should be
working on dark matter and it's like
yeah that's that's a strategy for for
research that I find can be problematic
when the motivation is just to be part
of the crowd but it's it's more just a
number of people right it's like is this
subject so it making so much progress
that it warrants the attention to it are
we ignoring subjects that are making
real progress that need more people
um and is that good healthy for the
people any sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable from
Magic
welcome everybody to the first episode
live in studio of the into the
impossible podcast in many many years we
are emerging from pandemic podcasting
and no one could be happier than ah your
fearful host formerly fearful host
Dr Brian Keating and I'm joined today
with a renowned cosmologist a
collaborator a colleague Professor Dan
Green welcome Daniel to the into the
impossible podcast hi Ryan great to see
you good to see you too so recording
live this is an experiment studio is
still a little bit ghetto it's gonna
improve yeah big guest coming up today
we're talking about Nobel dreams or
maybe not Nobel dreams no Gary Taos is
not here
um this is kind uh gift for Eric
Weinstein from Martin Bauer uh kind of
strange turn of events we'll get at this
amount of time we're talking about
things that aren't necessarily Nobel
recipients but are potentially Nobel
worthy and it's really prompted by
Daniel's amazing tweet storm of the
month of December which caused him to
really gain a tremendous amount of
well-deserved uh attention for his
perspicacity and everything that he does
he's an amazing colleague and I'm so
glad that we poached him away and I want
to give him an introduction but I want
him to do it so I don't get anything
wrong and that will commence right now
so damn where do you come from what's
your origin story we're cosmologist
you're a theorist I'm an experimentalist
we work together on many projects
including the Simon's Observatory and uh
what's your origin story tell tell the
audience where did you come from so yeah
so I am I grew up in Vancouver British
Columbia Canada
um I was uh a science fair and
Enthusiast and amateur astronomer as a
kid and uh stayed in Vancouver to go to
the University of British Columbia for
undergrad and and there I you know
interacted with a bunch of the local
famous as people like Bill unru who's
famous for the unbrew radiation
and uh after after spending four years
there I was ready to make the big move
to the United States for graduate school
and I went to Stanford
um where I studied with Eva Silverstein
who's well known in part because she's a
MacArthur Award winner but she is one of
these interesting people who Bridges the
boundary between many fields she's a
string theorist by training but it's
really interested in cosmology and while
I was there many other things like
condensed matter physics and so she was
kind of a
very broad person who liked to
investigate different interesting things
and so that rubbed off on me in a
certain way and so after graduate school
I moved to Princeton at The Institute
for advanced study and I tried a bunch
of different fields out and um in part
because of the presence of David spurgle
and Matthias aldiaga who were just some
of the most bullying people I'd ever met
that kind of uh their unique style of
just kind of doing everything in
cosmology was really intoxicating and I
kind of became a cosmologist from that
from that point forward and so from from
there I went back to Stanford and then
eventually to the University of Toronto
uh at the Canadian Institute for
theoretical astrophysics where we
poached you from yes indeed and so I was
there I also got to meet dick Bond who's
another just incredible cosmologist with
great stories about the history of the
subject that I had never been exposed to
so a lot of even in my list a lot of the
sort of what I was thinking of you know
what were big things I would think back
to conversations with dick where he
would kind of been like oh at this time
it was really this thing is really what
moves the field and so that's was a very
useful perspective for me and then I
moved here in 2017 and I've been here
I've been here ever since and now
associate professor it means you're
tenured which means you could speculate
and all sorts of crazy stuff like I like
to do already have your own podcast
someday
and certainly the uh the you're a must
follow on Twitter and uh I recommend
everybody do that because Daniel is he
uh I think you're unique in a lot of
ways you have a very high High command
of experimental results in the history
of the experimental field and I always
say and tell me what you teach your
students but I always say that
experimental is my students should
understand Theory as well as your
graduate students do but they're not
required to create new theories do you
feel well first of all how do you react
to that do you think a theorists should
have to understand experiments but not
do experiments I think I mean it's
different people have different styles
so for me there's always like I don't
think there's one right right way to do
it but you know what drew me to the
subject of cosmology is the ability to
go so I can distinctly remember a
meeting in Princeton where in the span
of one meeting David spurgle had kind of
brought up why a telescope they were
designing was going to have swinging
mirrors and then at the same time was
talking about topological defects in the
early Universe from a theoretical point
of view and for me that the idea that a
single conversation could cover all of
that ground and that one person could be
in command of all of those things at the
same time that was amazing and I I think
it's not for every subject right if
you're in particle physics like there's
a very hard line between really doing
experiment and doing Theory because if
you join the experiment there's like
rules you can't publish certain things
if you're part of the experiment and so
I I actually just that seems problematic
to me it would be nice if everyone could
find a balance between how much Theory
how much experiment worked for them
um but to your point on the coming from
the experimental side I do remember
there's like experimentalists sometimes
they hate it when theorists say oh we
need theorists to calculate things and
they're like I can calculate just fine
like like don't tell me I don't know how
to do math it's more the like it's the
new ideas right and then the health of
the field requires an inflex of new
ideas not just new calculations for
producing experiments so I I think that
a blend is is great and I think
cosmology that's the great thing about
our field is that that blend is very
alive and well in a way that maybe other
fields have become really split into
ethereum experience yeah and I think
that is you know so that has drawn me to
you know remain in the field dabble in
theory you know to whatever extent I'm
capable doing it always trying to have
one of my students who is more
theoretically inclined so to speak and
you know thankfully I've had a bunch
that have been phenomenal students and
any help to uh to you know kind of
Shepherd their careers through through
all the different um Hoops they have to
jump through and thankfully they're back
off their strike the picket line just a
quick pause to ask you for a small favor
while my thumb is occupied with old
Albert on it yours is presumably freed
up to leave a thumbs up on this video
really helps me a lot with a good
old-fashioned YouTube algorithm thanks a
lot now back to the video
um but I want to talk about this epic
you know tweet thread that you've had
and I'll have my editor uh flip that up
on the screen as we're talking I've got
millions of Impressions and and just
tremendous feedback and uh and a lot of
attention and I want to uh have you
explain the predicate for it what was
the sort of impetus why did you choose
to present it in this way and uh how did
you maintain your sanity and strength
during the month of December I can
hardly post stuff that other people
right forgot
he writes my tweets
um but uh what what was the impetus of
it had chicken so I you know it was one
of these things I think a lot about
what's important research just for
myself and I tell my students to as well
um you know I think it's valuable as an
exercise as a researcher to know sort of
what is what is a what is something that
would rise to the level of the best
result of the year or the best result of
five years the best result to 10 years
um and and I I tell them this in the
same way that you would think about like
what's your best movie of this year
imagine you're a filmmaker you know and
you want to know what makes a good good
movie we don't have to agree on what the
best movie is of all time or even the
best movie of the year but we can
probably agree that certain movies are
good and certain movies are not so good
and obviously it's nice to aim to make
movies that are good if you're a
filmmaker and for me it's the same with
research like I like I think everyone
knows that Einstein's contributions to
physics were important but like you had
even if you aspire to be Einstein like
no one just jumps into the Einstein you
have to like have some more modest goals
to take along the way and so I think
that's what's often missing for me and
the conversation around what's good and
bad research is like it's either there's
Einstein or there's nothing else and
it's like and I was just you know I'm
inspired all the time be like what's the
middle what was the best paper of the
past 10 years and then I don't know just
suddenly there's something my kids have
Advent calendars and so the month of
December is a time where there's a kind
of thing every day and I just like you
know what maybe it would be just fun to
every day of this month just put one of
these kind of ideas out there
um for people to digest and whether they
like it or not I felt like I could I
could do that it would be fun and you
know it wasn't hard to get 25
interesting papers because I wasn't
ordering them to be honest like doesn't
if it was like I was gonna do the best
paper then the second best paper I would
have agonized way more but it's just
like here's 31 papers I like you know
that's not that's not so so difficult
right and so we'll uh we'll go through a
couple of the the highlights and some of
them I just really could not agree with
you more and some of them I felt like oh
why didn't you leave this one off and
um and so we'll talk about the the one
you know the ones that were orphaned the
great results that you did but there was
one Criterion which was uh it could not
have been appeared in this book
um or this book uh Nobel dreams or into
the impossible money book um and why was
that what was that choice so it it might
like it aligns with your your uh
missions pretty well but actually like
the reason was just to make an
interesting list like I thought it was
like you know it's like saying your
favorite thing is puppies like No One's
Gonna disagree with that like I thought
to be an interesting list it had to be a
list of things that hadn't had that kind
of like obvious Acclaim that everyone
can agree on because I'm like yeah this
thing that won the Nobel Prize was a
good result it's like yeah great right
no duh but I thought you know just how
and again I didn't just Nobel Prize was
the easiest line to Drew but I drew some
other ones where I was like you know
that is so obvious that everyone would
have that on their list because it's so
well popularized and the fun of making a
list is to give some light on to things
that are sort of less well known the
same way that if you're a movie critic
like that's why they tend to be less
likely to put the Blockbuster that made
a billion dollars on the list because
like yeah everyone knows everyone's out
there and that's why they'll throw in
that like weird foreign film that no
one's heard of it was like this is my
opportunity to to sort of Castle
Lane on something I really appreciated
so that was the idea not because I had
any sort of anything against Nobel Prize
winners or one way or the other but just
just
so where did you start up what was the
first tweet and then the last tweet and
then we'll get to some of the the ones
that we can debate so so I started I
started with heavy Quark effective
Theory so heavy Quirk effective theory
was this idea that when you're thinking
about
um when you're thinking about uh states
of matter or particularly particles that
are made out of lots of quarks are made
out of quarks that include one whose
mass is very large there's a secret
trick to understand what what's going on
which is to kind of treat that one Quark
like it's infinitely heavy and this
trick has a way of explaining why a
bunch of these um these sort of baryonic
States tend to have similar properties
even though they're made out of
different combinations of quartz and
this idea was like this was the first
example uh where someone had taken a
theory that's written down and by kind
of expanding it in a non-obvious way
made new prop properties emerge that
were not obvious from the beginning so
there's kind of secret symmetries that
related different different states of
particles in a way that was you couldn't
have just said oh well we knew that from
the beginning and you just made it
obvious in some other way and and that's
the kind of that that was sort of the
first example at least in my knowledge
of the history of the subject of sort of
effective field Theory which is this
great thing that has really transformed
the field in the past 30 years where
effective field Theory wasn't just a way
of saying a result that people already
knew but really was a way of rethinking
about what physics is about where um by
focusing in on the scale of the problem
you care about what is the right way to
think about the theory you really make
you know you really make things obvious
that were not obvious before and so that
has happened there's been many many
further examples since and that was I
picked that one because I was like this
is the thing that kind of started at all
and um and our colleague Anish manohar
was one of the people who really pushed
that forward in the early 90s is and has
since discovered many other great
examples of this kind of like mysterious
things that come out of thinking about
what the right way to organize physics
problems is and um and so that was one
was like I picked that one as the first
one because it was the kind of thing
where I feel like people who really know
the subject know and that heavy Quirk
effective theory was important but like
it's kind of Niche like not very many
people know it and it deserves much more
credit is kind of spawning a lot of
development of the field and then the
last one which will be close to your
heart I imagine was the age of the
Universe
um this was sort of a measurement and
this was feeding back to our comment
about Dick Bond I really this was the
one that drove me crazy because because
the history is that it was really first
definitively pinned down by Cosmic
microwave background measurements but
dick would have would would tell me that
it was the boomerang experiment and the
analysis debated around Boomerang uh
which was which was before the satellite
W map which she usually gets the credit
for the measurement
um that was that was a big deal but the
part three is I put it on my list is
that when I was uh in Canada I worked on
a Space Telescope called most and the
proposal for most which was made in the
90s was that they were going to measure
the age of the universe by doing uh
Astro seismology to measure the age of
stars in our galaxies and when the
proposal was made from the mid to late
90s the age of the universe was so
uncertain that that was a compelling
thing to do like we literally didn't
know it was it eight billion years or 20
billion years and so pending down how
old Stars was seemed like a really
important problem and while they were
building that telescope CMV came along
and determined the age of the universe
to basically one percent and that
suddenly became overnight not an
interesting question but that's still
obliterates yeah now to be there to
their good luck though at the same time
that they were you know the fields were
evolving exoplanets came along and a
telescope that's really good at
measuring very small changes of light of
stars really excellent for exoplanets so
while their age of the universe science
Target disappeared exoplanets emerged
and so that was like you know it's the
give and take of science but um but I
but that one for me is very personally
resonant because I was coming along
right at that moment that was right when
you were kind of hitting maturity and
really becoming coming into your own as
a scientist and and thinking about
projects that could then take yours so
my first project on most was to do
exoplints I was the first person who
thought about exoplanets for most and it
was like it literally as an undergrad
they put me on this because I was like
this was not part of our proposal at all
right but it's obviously very important
science so it's the example of how new
targets emerge in the middle of a
project like you don't just do what the
project said how to do as a Serendipity
exactly is a great yeah that project
never so they launched it launched in
2003 I think on a Russian satellite
Russian rocket
um it was uh it was one of these
converted icbms I think at the time it
was the it was the um it was the rocket
that had put the most satellites into
independent orbits that had ever been
done using that great icdm technology to
hit multiple us targets and so they um
they did they had a couple of high
profile papers around asteroid
seismology
um but um but they did and they put some
upper limits on exoplanets but but the
thing that's really um challenging of X
Appliance is to see a light curve you
need to see the light reflected on
Clinton depends on the exact atmosphere
and so actually at the time as an
undergrad I got to work with Sarah
Seeger because she was the one who was
making these guests on the internet and
she um and so she had these atmosphere
models and so we were using her
atmosphere models just to predict what
it might look like and they were so
uncertain at the time it was totally
possible that most could detect it and
they ended up setting some interesting
upper limits but were unable to actually
see those like oh fantastic okay well
let's get back to the the Tweets in just
a minute but I did want to
um take a detour into a subject that's
very very prominently featured on this
channel which is the crisis in physics
so we've had probably three dozen
podcasts or interviews or webinars with
my friends at the PBS space time and
others saying it basically is physics
and crisis we've had on guests like the
Sabine hassenfelder Neil Turok who the
episode is called physicism crisis uh
we've had on Eric Weinstein we've had on
many many kind of iconoclastic people
but uh We've also had on many many you
know kind of uh supporters that physics
is doing just fine and we should stop
the history on XML about what's wrong
with physics but let's let's talk about
that how do you react to
um these claims that you know physics is
is uh suffering uh not the crisis of
tensions those are healthy we'll talk
about those
um and we'll talk about some unhealthy
you know maybe corollaries to those
tensions that people use a tension or
research direction or a Lacuna in the
big bang you know CDN model to kind of
call Doubt cast out upon all of physics
or something stupid like that but we'll
talk about shouldn't say stupid strike
that strike that from the right uh but
but um clickbaity you know yes I've been
guilty of myself but anyway
um but let's talk about physics is
physics and crisis what what is this
notion that people seem to want to
believe almost that we're these
physicists are chasing angels dancing
and peanuts well I think
I think what I would say is that my as I
try to emphasize my my thought process
around what's good and bad science like
try to have a very you know nuanced view
because it's important for me as a
research and so I would say the thing
that I so to I will first say the thing
I agree with which in this context
it's always it's typically around are we
crisis zeroing in on really one field
it's usually like there's a group of
people working on this one thing is this
one thing going to lead for progress and
the reality is research is very complex
there's people doing all kinds of
different things and so to say physics
is not making progress it's often just
completely ignoring huge swaths of the
community that are making real progress
but the part where I would agree with I
would say that I at least agree with the
spirit of it is that
particle physics in particular as a
phenomena where people tend to kind of I
describe them in physics terms they're
like bosons they all like to do the same
thing right they don't like whereas
fermions like to not be in the same
state so if one person's working on a
subject in other fields like one
person's working on a subject like oh
someone's got that covered I should go
do something else whereas a particle
physics it tends to be oh everyone's
thinking about Dark Matter that's the
thing I should be working on dark matter
and it's like yeah that's that's a
strategy for for research that I find
can be problematic when the motivation
is just to be part of the crowd right
and if we don't have good checks on are
we making progress and again we could be
making progress but the question is is
the progress worth the number of people
working on it and so I think in a new
idea about this String Theory yeah so
stranger is exactly the same but I want
I want I want to spread it because
String Theory the criticism is also that
it doesn't make contact with experiment
and I would say I don't see it
necessarily as being an issue of contact
with experiment there's great results
that didn't intend to be in contact with
experiment when they started they may
contact later and there's some of those
on my list on purpose for that reason
but it's it's more just a number of
people right it's like is this subject
so it making so much progress that it
warrants the attention to it or we
ignoring subjects that are making real
progress and need more people
um and and is that good healthy for the
field and so I would say my point of
view is at times I'm frustrated that
there's not more people working on
inflationary cosmology a subject close
to my heart
um and and that there's perhaps more or
because more emphasis on Dark Matter
than maybe I find is warranted but dark
matter I also think is the correct
theory of cosmology all the data and not
my point of view is that it's absolutely
correct and we should definitely look
for it and there's just some you know
it's around the edges you know how much
how much attention does it warrant you
know are setting bounds on models of
dark matter that no one in the right
mind thinks it's the model of nature a
worthy use of time or should they be
exploring more generally and okay those
are I think legitimate things to worry
about is the health of any field as this
you know how does sociology affect what
people feel they can and cannot spend
their time on so I think from that point
of view I agree that there's a reason to
worry but there's a reason to worry all
the time right like the the healthy
people would say inflation gets way more
attention than bouncing cosmological
models
so I would say in that example I I know
the field in that case and I would say
you know I don't I think there's a lot
in this sort of clickbaity way which is
like people and I think this is true to
most of the criticism which I'll come to
which is the criticism also tends to
paint researchers as complete as not
thinking about why they spend their time
on what they do and and again they think
about it but in this complicated way
they think about it both from like if I
choose to work on this thing like and
not like is it going to ruin my career
um and that just being like looking at
the job prospects and saying like hey
there's not a job ad that says you know
to work on this weird topic and that
might influence what they do but within
the co within any area that you're
working on you're not oblivious to why
you pick one model over the other so the
reason people work on dark matter is is
not because they're not aware that it
could have been explained by something
that's not dark matter it's because you
can look at the they've thought about
the ways in which something is not dark
matter might manifest and the data
doesn't support those kinds of ideas and
the same is true with balancing
cosmology so all of the people so from
my point of view I actually think the
debate between mounts and cosmologies
and inflation isn't the most exciting
thing to me because to me they both
solve the same problem and more or less
the same way like I don't see bouncing
as really that big a deviation from
inflation it it's just slightly
different and I honestly don't care
which one it is I happen to think the
data it's easier to make a model of
inflation and as I work on inflation but
actually a lot of the tools I use would
apply equally well to balancing
Technologies so it's not so I would say
like the idea that I have some I am
absolutely you know I religiously
against Mountain cosmologists first that
have some deep seated Prejudice like I
would be totally fine with the bouncing
pathology if someone wrote a model that
worked better than relation to be like
yeah that's totally fine I kind of see
it like are you familiar with something
called the Ikea effect no no uh it's
where you um they take people uh and
they give them a piece of you know high
quality Furniture like this which uh and
they even from Ikea and they say build
this on this table and they build it and
then they have another group or they
even the same group and basically the
same table but they just give it to them
and the people that built the table
themselves value it 10x
from a uh you know I feel like people
are so invested in whatever Paradigm
this is true you know power law
independent of what field we're in but
it just so happens that you and I are
both cosmologists
um that we see it that people are really
entrenched in it and so that's why
people like Paul steinhardt who did have
a lot of you know so-called sunk cost
you know yeah into inflation it's so
impressive to me that he can pivot uh
you know people that come up and just
and you know for their whole career have
been entrenched and oh the Big Bang
never happened and all these other
things um but uh so let's do a little
bit more on string theory um a lot of
the claims that I had on Cameron baffa
and I've had on avilo and Erica and
Sabina and the the claims that I always
hear is that they don't make you know
testable predictions they make a lot of
retroductions and actually to be fair uh
come run you know he had a wonderful
appearance in one of my most popular
episodes to put a link somewhere yeah
and he said no no Brian you're wrong you
know secretary does make predictions it
predicts that the mass of the electron
is you know between you know 10 to the
minus uh you know one plank masses to
you know 10 to minus 30 plaque masses
you know it's in a Range it makes
prediction it could be you know 10 to
the 80th that would be inconsistent what
do you make I mean that was and I asked
him I said what's like give me something
that is a concrete you know answer the
Skeptics we have a saying in Judaism you
know know what to say to a heretic so
tell me you know like how do you react
to that I mean is that what would you
use oh so actually I okay
my PhD advisor yeah we'll be very much
upset if I if I were just to not defend
the strength very very strongly but to
be honest like I I don't see the value
of string theory in terms of whether it
makes experimental predictions or not
like I think the attempt to put it into
the does it predict particle physics or
not you know hasn't been very successful
and I know that there's you know lots I
I read all the papers when I was a grad
student of people trying to make models
of a standard model and like I just I
don't find that to be particularly
useful as a scientist who Now does not
spend most of my time doing String
Theory however I find many results in
string theory useful to what I do and a
lot of what's called string theory is
you know now you know the impact is sort
of as laying the foundation for the laws
of physics that we then use so one one
of the examples I I brought up in this
um
I brought up in in this this list was
the um what's called the conformal
bootstrap and it's sort of you know one
of the applications is to try to make
sense of you know what are those
restrictions on theories of quantum
gravity that are inspired by you know
what we know about String Theory but the
exact technique that is being used in
that one case to understand quantum
gravity and anti-decider space which is
what lots of string throws do is
actually also the best way we have to
predict what will happen to helium 4 at
this particular critical point yes that
has been measured and it's one of these
things that's like yeah they didn't set
out when they were thinking about
quantum gravity right to predict what
helium does matter that was not what
anyone thought they were doing when they
were thinking about black holes but at
the same time like that it is making a
real experimental prediction there and
like it it's really useful in that
regard and so for me it's more like the
value String Theory as a research
Endeavor is more in that regard like I
as a person trained in string theory I
so I as an undergrad I worked on leukron
and gravity and with Bill unru and you
know uh at UBC and then I went to grad
school and worked on string theory and I
used neither one in my like directly in
my day-to-day work now but the things I
learned by learning String Theory inform
a lot of what I do like there's a lot of
just ideas that came out of string
theory that you can remove the string
theory are super useful ideas and they
really change how I think about physics
the stuff I learned about gravity has
not been useful at all right and so from
my point of view it's like well okay and
again this is the attention thing right
like you could say you know given how
many people work on string theory has it
delivered enough and I think that's a
fair question to ask but I wouldn't go
so far as to say strenglers are useful
because there are many many results in
string theory that have really helped me
understand the universe and come up with
tests that we can do in cosmology to
understand how you know how structure
was created and you know quick question
when you're looking at and you and I
serving a lot of committees you know we
have as I say we have the hardest three
hour a week job in the world there's no
way around it then right I mean uh we
have these committees that mean you know
every quarter but sometimes hiring
committees and we have to look forward
to faculty and we get 400 applications
for a single position it's so much more
Cutthroat than than when you join let
alone when I joined you know the ranks
of Faculty 19 years ago I can't believe
it uh but uh but the point being do you
have like a goal is there a rubric like
string theorist wanted and loop crime
gravity you know obviously you're gonna
say no like we don't so there's anybody
that's based on Merit but um but talk
about like because people say well
there's too much effort going into it
but I can't tell my student I can't
force my student you have to work on the
Simon's Observatory or Simon's array
polar bear you can't force if they don't
want to work I don't think go to a
different grade they join your group uh
or do something else so um to what
extent do we really have anything to the
to the people that say like there's too
much going into this field what what do
you how do you answer that well so in a
practical sense well I mean again this
is where for me like that that's it's
part of taste right like if if you ask
someone what their favorite movies are
and they're all terrible movies probably
not going to give them money to make
their next movie right because you kind
of know what they're doing and so if I
if we hire someone who I feel has just a
nose for interesting ideas and through
that process it leads them to lukewarm
gravity or at least into String Theory
like I will trust that they have good
taste and they know why they're doing it
but I don't also think that being
dogmatic about it like we will hire
someone because we need someone who
knows how to calculate some processes we
don't need people to calculate anything
has established reports the new ideas
that we care about so you know I think
to what the great thing about our
institution is that our Theory group is
very diverse in the topics they work on
but I think we all have both a Common
Language of effective field Theory so I
think that's usually the thing if you
don't understand effective field Theory
it's hard to know it's an interesting
problem and not an interesting problem
so what that subject has done for the
world is it took the space of problems
and it really organized them in a way
where hard problems were obvious and
easy problems were obvious and
interesting problems were obvious and So
within our group we all have a
collective understanding of that and so
we can all communicate to each other
some some people were trying to string
theory some of them not some of them
very critical String Theory some of them
very supportive of the string theory but
if you put us all in a room and you say
why are you working on this problem they
can instantly communicate to everyone
else in the room while that's an
interesting problem and everyone will
come away going yeah that's a really
interesting problem yeah and and if if
you can hire people like that like
that's fantastic
work on like they'll tell you why it's
interesting after they figure something
out and that's simple I think what's
important now talk about uh let's go
back to your Tweet storm uh so any
controversial choices did you get
feedback from uh from your vast
audiences so hopefully it'll grow but uh
anything controversial so I actually got
less feedback that I was expecting I was
I was expecting to get a little bit more
pushback on some of the choices
um I would say the the one obvious
Omission that I had which was very
intentional was uh ads CFT which is this
idea that you know quantum gravity and
anti-decider space were just some space
that's not our universe is equal uh
mathematically to
um uh conventional Quantum field Theory
um and this was a it's like the most
cited paper of I think it is like the
most cited paper and theoretical physics
at this point and you know I left it off
it was written in what was it 97 and I
left it off for the same reason I left
off Nobel prizes not because I also
because you know it again it evokes so
many emotions when you bring up that
paper because it's so well known and for
me I thought you know that's it's it's
so it's been incredibly useful for
things that ended up being connected to
experiment but I'd rather zoom in on the
things that ended up being that that
came after that ended up being really
useful and clearly progress because
everyone already knows what it is yeah
and then uh Supernova 1987a that caught
my eye talk about that what did that so
I put that I I so I'm glad you caught
that one because I that was one I was I
was proud of to have on the list and and
again to to to to connect back to um to
to your many many written documents
about the Nobel Prize like I I like
separating science from the people that
do science like there's people that do
science are important but what I was
trying to get at with a list yeah is
like I don't care about who did it I
care about like the thing that was
important right and so putting putting a
an event and not a paper or not a thing
was was useful because Supernova 19 1987
a core collapse super open the large
magellanic Cloud it's the closest
Supernova we've been able to observe in
the modern era where we have technology
particularly neutrino detectors and so
it was this unique event that a lot of
people point to as like the moment when
particle physics and astronomy kind of
merged into this particle astrophysics
because we had the direct observations
with light but we also had these
neutrinos that came out of the Supernova
and showed up in our detectors and like
to this day like there are many many
papers in particle physics every year
that are like this new person had this
idea but the observation of the
Supernova in 1987 rules it out because
like our it gives us this window what
happened at extremely high densities
that we can't make on Earth and like
it's just life right like we have it's
not like nobody wrote a proposal for
that neutrino thing I mean they might
have said oh if we're lucky enough that
a supernova happens nearby then we could
do something with it but the actual
impact on the field has been enormous
and long lasting because we don't get
Supernova like that all the time and so
I that was the one where I thought it
was the most obvious the scientific
value of the event where there's no like
person you point to when you say this
was important because this person had
this idea it was like just important
because it happened right fun fact that
Supernova indirectly led to me being
here because it was discovered uh when I
was a you know in Middle High School or
late high school early high school and
uh it was really you know kind of
surprising I thought oh there's a
supernova every Century Galaxy no we
haven't had a supernova a long time and
maybe that's a good thing but um it was
discovered by uh I think Robert
sanderlique who's an astronomer at Case
Western Reserve University which okay as
you know from my interview with Stacy
McGraw and uh and Glenn starkman
um talk about you know so next after
kind of CMB which I'm still having such
uh directly a lot of places honorable
mentions yeah although that could mean
you know we're due for more and more
Nobel prizes right
um talk about the uh talk about the
appearance of you know Susie I mean to
some people they'd say oh Susie's rolled
out right so what extent is Susie rolled
out and why did it feature so you know
it's I did a histogram you know and I
had your tweets and Susie appears pretty
frequently so I think the the main tool
use of supersymmetry in the the
instances on my list is as a tool to
solve Quantum field theories and and the
reason I S and the reason I I like to to
sort of put it in that perspective is
that toy models are very valuable in
physics right like and and not even just
in physics like I think the icing model
which is this model which we use to
understand magnetism is now like used to
understand machine learning like it's
like they're like these toy models that
we can solve and we can understand all
the Dynamics of are incredibly powerful
in in every domain of physics so I'll
give you a quote of this story as Steve
Capleton who's a very famous condensed
matter theorist at Stanford
um I took a class against metaphysics
through when I was in grad school and at
the beginning of the class for like
we've really done anything he said if
you want to be a successful condensed
matter physicist you just pick one of
these models like it doesn't even matter
what the model is and you study
literally everything about it you study
what happens when it's a strong company
a week up like at high temperature low
temperature you just do literally
everything and then the rest of your
career whenever anyone comes up to you
with a new idea you say oh that's just
like an icing model when it blah blah
blah this happens and it was like it was
a very useful comment because that that
is the use of these toy models is that
they just give you a way to sort of in a
way that you can solve understand what
complicated systems do and so I so a lot
of the use of supersymmetry whether or
not it's true in the real world is it
allows us to solve for Quantum field
theories like what happens in them that
we literally can't solve and the ones
that are closer to the real world so we
can understand nuclear physics in a
super symmetric World mathematically and
improve all kinds of very important
results that help us understand what
real world Nuclear Physics could do or
real world strongly coupled systems
where it's hard to solve the equations
ourselves and so as a tool it's been
incredibly powerful just as a way to
think about dynamics of you know
complicated systems absolutely uh so in
the next subject that I want to turn to
just in a couple minutes we have before
we have to get over to The Faculty Club
for our Friday afternoon scotches
um there's uh is are topics that didn't
make the list so sometimes that's even
more revelatory even than obviously you
only had 31 days to make these uh epic
tweet storms uh possible but um tell me
a couple that you if you had uh to go
into you know February the shortest
month uh by the way do you know which
month has 28 days in it
do you want things that didn't make the
list because of my rules or things I
would add to the list so I had more time
yeah let's do one of each okay so I
would say if I had more so one of them
that probably qualifies that I didn't
add to my list not for any good reason
was the study of proton decay so proton
decay is um like we have all these
really interesting theories that predict
that proton should Decay right and um we
really don't have a good reason for
thinking that protons are stable and um
the study of proton decay was inspired
by these Grand unified theories that
predicted it should be there and it
really took off in the 80s and in the
80s it really killed a lot of ideas that
were at the time very considerate very
realistic to be how the world worked
yeah that's I think uh the the sort of
early
um like sc5 models in that are not super
symmetric are they the supersymmetric
ones are still alive but if we could do
better in proton okay we could really
just either find or rule out some of our
most exciting ideas for Grand unified
theories but they just it was this
example of something that you know like
it came out of theory but it's a great
test to do and Theory kind of motivated
doing a thing we should have done anyway
and and I think I think that would have
made my list because it's very
influential how people thought about
particle physics and kind of like people
thought they were really going to see it
at the level predicted by these early
Grand unified models and it was kind of
the first thing that didn't go according
to plan like the standard model kind of
came along and everything that a
predicted was seen and I think a lot of
people in the 80s thought okay you know
we saw the W bar the W boson we're now
going to see proton decay and
everything's going to go according to
plan and that was the first thing that
kind of didn't go as we thought it might
and um and I think in that regard you
might to say like it was very
influential both in a good and bad way
but but that was like I mean it's it's
hard to overstate the kind of sense in
which like both if we ever saw anything
that would be incredible but just that
the balance that exists now or some of
our most sensitive tests of physics that
we can't see directly so that was one I
think I think it would qualify under my
rules but I didn't want to dig into the
history is very complicated of where do
you draw the line yeah exactly and then
and then one that didn't that didn't
meet it for because it failed my my
rules that I really love is this
prediction that the absence of seeing
temperature fluctuations in the in the
CMB in the 1980s
um uh meant that there had to be dark
matter so there's this great argument so
if you go back in time to when they you
know first saw the CME they said what's
really smooth temperature in every
direction is the same but the universe
we see is very not smooth there's lots
of stuff everywhere uh Planet Stars
galaxies and this had to come out of
that smooth starting point and in a
universe that only has the kind of
matter that we experience you can say
okay well the stuff there's big
fluctuations today there's planet Earth
here not over there that's a big change
in the density and from what we know it
the given when the CM when we observe
the CMB in the history of the universe
and where we are today the temperature
fluctuation should be one part a
thousand it can't be any smaller than
that or there's just no way it could
have worked and uh they didn't see it at
one part in a thousand they didn't even
see it at one part in ten thousand so by
by 1980 they knew that there was no
fluctuation one part of ten thousand and
people throughout this paper in 1982
that's like that means there's dark
matter right like they're like that's
the only thing that I can put this
obvious thing I can think of that we
have some kind of evidence for already
right but like that's that's what's
going on because otherwise we thought we
were supposed to see in what part of a
thousand we're definitely not finding it
and that paper so it fails my rule
because I had said I was only going to
take papers after 1983. so but then the
second thing is it's technically cited
in the Nobel Prize for peoples but
people I mean that's kind of unfair
because people kind of like occur it's
like a creative career you can't say
every paper that people ever wrote
doesn't count to the list but the other
thing about it is like if you look at
the citation industry it was getting
like 10 citations a year for you know 40
years that's just I think that's
criminal it's such a beautiful idea that
it really like I I just feel bad that
it's not good I didn't get more
attention but speaking of uh Professor
Jim Peebles invited on the show he had a
great book came out last year he also
had two years ago now hey
um he had a wonderful paper called
anomalies and cosmology which came out
late at the end of last year which in
which he goes through all these tensions
and kind of crises and but from a real
obviously the highest caliber of
physicists right now
um I hope we can talk about that in a
part two because uh and other things the
crises the Hubble tension uh Dark Matter
crisis other phenomena that we have as
well as you know how can we get more and
better students uh around the world to
come into physics and what you're
optimistic about in physics and what
you're kind of hoping will change in our
in our physics both from the uh you know
depth the breadth the diversity of of
who we can appeal to and bring in Under
the Tent but I want to thank you uh for
spending uh this little hour with us in
my audience and you're going to be
definitely an audience favorite I hope
you'll come back again soon many many
more times uh and I hope I can call upon
you whenever there's a calculation
I still have to sing the alphabet song
to know what comes after R it's
embarrassing um Dan and green Professor
Dan and green one of the brightest
people I know bluest lame thinker uh uh
you know in this in this neck of the
universe uh thank you so much thanks
Brian this was awesome
[Music]